This paper can simulate really sophisticated
virtual material models.
Here, billions and billions of numbers describe
the reflectance properties of these materials.
But, material properties are not the only
thing that is important in a virtual world.
Textures are important too.
And with textures, I have good news and bad
news for you.
Good news: they look fantastic, so much so
that you can take a photograph from the real
world and add it to your video games.
Bad news: they take a ton of data.
Gigabytes and gigabytes of data that is often
too much for real-time applications and handheld
devices.
And sometimes, it is too much even for big
honking machines and video games.
Why?
Well, you see in a video game or virtual world,
when we get closer to an object, we need to
see more detail.
Imagine going closer to an open book, and
suddenly, a blurry mess emerges.
What instead should happen is that we should
be able to even read that book.
So, what does that require?
Storing more detail means, yes, you’ve guessed
right, Fellow Scholars, that means storing
even more data.
So, what is the solution?
Well, if too much data is the problem, is,
of course, the solution is compression.
Compression means making things smaller.
More compact.
We are in luck, because these shiny neural
networks are excellent at compression.
We just saw how well they have done this job
with the material models here.
They are also excellent at compressing simulation
data.
So, scientists at NVIDIA said, let’s do
exactly that here too.
And now, hold on to your papers Fellow Scholars,
and look.
This is the previous technique, and this is
the new one.
For approximately the same amount of data
storage, this can provide so much better quality.
Wow.
That is excellent.
But wait, is it excellent enough for real-time
applications?
I mean, how many seconds does it take to then
decompress this and use it in our games?
Dear Fellow Scholars, and this is where I
fell off the chair when reading this paper.
It is not seconds.
A thousand times less.
Yes.
Just approximately one millisecond.
That is all it takes to decompress all this
information.
And you are going to love this one.
Do you see this flickering?
This is the process of compression by the
neural network.
It means that it is at work now.
The flickering arises as the technique is
trying a lot of different, but similar ways
to compress it down.
Okay, so is this good?
Is it doing better over time or worse?
Well, look here.
Here you see the signal to noise ratio, this
is the quality of the reconstruction, the
higher the better.
And, oh my, I love this.
Over time, this is increasing steadily, and
don’t forget, the decibel scale is logarithmic,
which means a lot of things, but among those
lot of things, it means that even a small
numerical difference means a big difference
in quality.
So, how long does this take?
Days?
Hours?
Ah, wait.
We are done.
The whole process took less than a minute
per texture.
That is excellent.
So, with that, if we have this beautiful inkwell
in a video game, with previous technique,
when going closer to it, we saw this, and
now, we see this.
And all this in real time.
That is incredible.
Because of the papers, next level games and
virtual worlds are coming.
But wait, one more final question.
This looks good, but what would be the proper,
real solution?
How much information did we lose during this
compression?
And the answer is.
Almost nothing.
Wow.
Note that this technique is specifically designed
for storing textures, and thus, it also includes
compressing different versions of the same
image together that we call mip levels and
some more magic.
And, here is a bombshell result.
The previous technique could do this, the
new technique can do this.
Wow, that book is readable even if we magnify
it a great deal.
And, my goodness.
Look at that!
It looks nearly the same as the true solution,
and takes about 45 times less data.
Phew!
And do not worry for a second, a bunch of
other techniques are also tested against in
the paper.
Now, not even this one is perfect.
For very low bitrates, when we are really
short on memory, not so good.
Still better than previous techniques, but
not ideal.
But that is an incredible jump in quality
in just one paper.
Loving it.
What a time to be alive!